el aniversario de la primera muerte
conocida por el nuevo coronavirus pasó
desapercibido este lunes en luján una
ciudad decidida a borrar su etiqueta de
zona cero del coronavirus
pujante en el virus bajo control ha
pasado un año y hoy buján en la ciudad
más segura de china el país entero
también está a salvo cuando el gobierno
declaró la epidemia el pueblo de buján
no le prestó tanta atención porque
estaba emergiendo por primera vez
entonces es importante recordar el
aniversario porque puede recordar al
pueblo de wuhan y de hecho a todo el
pueblo chino a ser conscientes de la
epidemia
poco se sabe aún de la primera víctima
incluido su nombre mientras que el
mercado al que se remontan los primeros
casos ha permanecido cerrado hasta ahora
el gobierno no ha permitido el acceso de
expertos independientes ni a este
mercado ni a la ciudad en el equipo de
la organización mundial de la salud de
encargado de investigar los orígenes de
la pandemia que debía llegar a china la
semana pasada comenzará su misión
el jueves anunciaron el ministerio de
salud chino y la ms es una visita muy
delicada para china interesada en
descartar toda responsabilidad de la
epidemia que ha causado más de 19
millones de muertos en el mundo más al
norte el país enfrenta pequeños rebrotes
en varias provincias en ávila provincia
que rodea a beijing se reportaron cerca
de 100 infecciones en las últimas 24
horas la cifra nacional más alta desde
julio la provincia está en confinamiento
y el gobierno ha cancelado las
celebraciones del año nuevo en beijing y
otras 7 provincias incluida juve y de la
que buscan es capital